[Music]
did you ever hear the tragedy
of darth plagueis the wise
i thought not well to make a long story
short
darth plagueis was a dark lord of the
sith
who was so powerful that he could
actually use the
force to influence midichlorians to
prolong
someone's life indefinitely or even
create new life from nothing
now we're of course not the ones to say
whether or not that's actually possible
and even if it was we certainly wouldn't
want to be the ones to teach you
how to do it the dark side of the force
is a pathway
to many abilities some including us here
at journey to the microcosmos consider
to be unnatural
[Music]
but what we can teach you is more about
midichlorians those powerful little
beings
that hold the secrets of the force
[Music]
midichlorians are sentient microscopic
organisms that reside
inside each and every living cell of
your body
and it's believed they originated at the
wellspring of
life a mystical world located
in the center of the galaxy over
thousands of years we have come to
depend on midichlorians just
as they have come to depend on us we
have developed
a symbiotic relationship we are two life
forms
living together
[Music]
well actually we are way more than just
two
life forms a person's midi-chlorian
count is determined
not by the number of midichlorians in
their body
but by the number of midichlorians per
cell
in their body and the average person's
midi-chlorian count is around 2500
which means they have about 2500
midichlorians
packed into each one of the trillions of
cells
in their body if you're curious about
your own midi-chlorian count
the easiest way to figure that out is
with a simple blood test
for most people though knowing their
midi-chlorian count
isn't all that important you can lead
just as healthy a life with a count of
fifteen hundred as you can with a count
of seven thousand personally i'm at
about thirty seven hundred
for those of you who might be wondering
when you start to get to counts closer
to
ten thousand well that's when things
start to become interesting you see the
higher your midi-chlorian count is
the more likely you are to be able to
connect
with the force that energy field created
by
all living things a field that surrounds
us and penetrates us
and binds the whole freaking galaxy
together
and for those people with midi-chlorian
counts around 10 000
the chances of being able to harness and
use the force
are so high that if their skills are
discovered at a young enough
age they have a good chance of being
trained to become a jedi
in fact all of the samples we're looking
at today
come from the collection stored in the
archives at the jedi temple on
coruscant this sample here was taken
from jedi master bala rapal
when he was just three years old and it
shows
that he had a midi-glorian count of just
over eleven thousand
putting him somewhere around jedi master
plocoon
but far below that of anakin skywalker
who has a count
of well over twenty thousand
now obviously not all of us get to be
jedi
and you shouldn't feel like bant the
fodder if your midi-chlorian count is
lower than average people with lower
midichlorian counts
have been known to be force sensitive in
the past
even if it's not quite as common but
looking at the bigger picture
we must remember that without
midichlorians
could not exist and without them
we would have no knowledge of the force
at all the midichlorians are continually
speaking to us
telling us the will of the force and
with time
you can also learn to quiet your mind
and hear them speaking to you
in those moments when i'm trying to sit
back and quiet my mind
i always find it helpful to reflect on
the words of the great
jedi master qui-gon jinn your focus
determines your reality
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and may the force be
with you
[Music]
also thank you to all of our patrons on
patreon all of these people
who let us you know do this on april 1st
when maybe we all need a little bit of
relaxation
and distraction if you'd like to see
more from our jedi master of microscopes
james weiss check out
jam and germs on instagram and if you
would like to
follow us deeper into the galaxy
that lies just beneath our site
you can go to youtube.com microcosmos
you